jill jones author of empires of light
Edison Tesla Westinghouse and the race
to electrify the world why did you write
this book well I was actually reading an
old biography of George Westinghouse and
there are several chapters devoted to
this war of the electric currents and
what caught me was this description of
Thomas Edison and how he helped develop
and promote the first use of the
electric chair as a tactic to smear
Westinghouse who was his rival in this
race this very bitter business rivalry
and corporate feud as to who would
dominate this nascent electrical
industry that they the two of them were
racing to develop and I I just found
that so astonishing I thought of Edison
as really a benevolent genius kind of a
folksy and wonderful person this was a
dark side of him that I had really
didn't know and when I looked into the
rest of the story I just find it so
compelling is the idea of a world in
which there was an electricity was very
fascinating idea as a historian to try
and take you back to that time and then
develop this wonderful set of characters
as they really struggled to make
electricity a commonplace how'd you go
about it well um I think the way you
research most history you start by
looking at books other people have
written and there are lots of books
about Edison a few books a few books
about Nikola Tesla who's in a key
character in this because he develops
the alternating system of electricity
which we used to this day and the George
Westinghouse was a very famous
Pittsburgh corporate warrior and but
with him there were really only these
two old biography
so he was actually the most elusive of
the three time frame for the book the
book really starts in 1879 when Edison
has invented the light bulb and it ends
in 1897 when they celebrate the first
transmission of alternating current
electricity 26 miles from Niagara Falls
to buffalo and that's really the
beginning of the electric grid which
just collapsed in the summer in 1879 how
much electricity was there in the United
States very little there was electricity
that was basically run off of batteries
and that ran the Telegraph a very small
number of telephones and there were also
starting in the very early 1880s
something called arc lights and those
did run off of generators in fact
alternating current generators and they
were a very brilliant what kind of
sizzling form of light they functioned
by having these two carbon pencils and
the electricity kind of jumped between
them and that created this very almost
painful to look at light so they would
it could only be used in extremely large
spaces or outdoors and so you would have
in a city a very tall pole almost like a
mast of a ship and at the top of that
would be these arc lights and that would
light up big public spaces homes lighted
anywhere in eighteen seventy nine not
with electricity what Edison boasted to
the world that he would do is he would
subdivide the light and what he meant by
this was the electric light that now was
so brilliant and bright in public spaces
what most houses had if they were in a
city was gas light and what this meant
is that gasp came into your house
through pipes and came to every fixture
you had to turn it on and light it which
meant usually had to take off the glass
globe otherwise what people had were
kerosene lamps which I think most of us
are familiar with still from camp
and so forth and candles that was what
you let your house with now you start
this book by defining things like volts
amps ohms well ohms is a law volts is a
term of pressure it's you know the
number of volts gives you an idea of the
pressure that's sending the electricity
out amps is actually just the amount of
power and then resistance is electricity
goes out generally on a copper wire and
that substance is creating a resistance
to the electricity as it travels on it
and so the way you calculate how much
electricity is going out as a function
of these three I guess terms the reason
I mentioned those three they were all
three people exactly who was Volta well
Volta was the first man he was an
Italian count to create a functional
battery and one of the things that was
fun about doing these books is learning
the people behind the names and he put
together a battery that would be
alternating discs of zinc and copper and
in between would be saturated like thick
paper and he then put in various saline
solutions and once these things all got
going they created electricity because
before that the only way you could
manufacture electricity was sent through
something called an electrostatic
machine and you would rub this and it
would the rubbing would create
electricity which you then would capture
in a Leyden jar and they would stay
there maybe for a few days and if you
touched the jar big jolts of electricity
would come out and so I have a chapter
that describes this very early of
electrically history of electricity you
know starting with Amber you rub amber
and you get an electrostatic charge and
that was really the first clue
that there was this invisible energy
that could make things happen but how
did you harness it and how did you come
to understand it because it is invisible
who was ampere well ampere was a very
brilliant French mathematician and
really what he did was just to create
some mathematical understandings of
electricity as it was being developed so
he was essentially developing formulas
who was ohms ohm was a German and he was
the man who came up with Ohm's law which
is volts equals amps times resistance so
there you have an Italian a Frenchman
and a German right and then there's a
guy named kelvin I don't know much about
electricity and all but there isn't Lord
Kelvin he was originally known as Sir
William Thompson and when he was most
famous for was helping to lay the
atlantic cable and make it work between
england and the united states and that
was a huge accomplishment and he also 0
created figured out all kinds of aspects
again of the the physical nature of
electricity and he plays a very
important role in one aspect of the war
of the electric currents who else is in
this picture well to the left of Lord
Kelvin is George Westinghouse and we
don't know who's to the right but there
are all in at Westinghouse's factory in
pittsburgh and i should say that
westinghouse was a man who had very few
photos I guess it's kind of indicative
of the different personalities hear that
westinghouse I don't think there's
probably even 20 photos of him as
opposed to someone like Edison who was
enormously famous celebrity and beloved
of the press there may be thousands of
photos of Edison but they're certainly
hundreds Thomas Alva Edison what can you
tell us about him
well he was a wonderfully interesting
man it was obviously our greatest
inventory still remain so is more than a
thousand patents which remains the
record for anyone American inventor and
at this particular moment he had already
invented the quadruplex Telegraph he was
very famous for that even more
astonishing because it was completely
original he had invented the talking
phonograph and so as he and he had many
smaller kinds of inventions but those
were his two really big ones and that he
had become very wealthy from and so as
we start this book in 1879 a friend has
convinced him that he should get
interested in electricity and takes him
off to see some arc lights at a factory
in Connecticut where is he living then
he's opened his so-called invention
factory in Menlo Park New Jersey which
is a very bucolic rural spot so that oh
his feeling is that he's brought all his
men and equipment and machines out from
Newark and this way they can really work
completely unimpeachably thing and it's
right on the pennsylvania railroad line
so that people can get back and forth
very easily and once you see these arc
lights he is set afire with ambition he
thinks this is the future and it's just
starting and I still have a chance and
he's not interested in arc lights to him
that's something that's very limited
because it's only going to be in the
public and in big spaces he wants to
subdivide the light and he rushes back
to menlo park he starts working on
inventing a functional incandescent
light bulb because for decades various
inventors on the continent in the United
States had been trying to figure out how
to do this and Edison has this
incredible innate sense of PR and he's
very beloved of the newspapers because
he has this folksy persona where these
blue workmen's outfits and he's always
covered with grease and he
makes these very amusing remarks so the
press loves them and within a week after
having visited the the arclight
inventors up in Connecticut he's
summoned a reporter from the New York
Sun to announce that he has he has
prevailed he has invented an
incandescent light bulb and that's not
all he's announcing he's announcing that
he is going to bring electricity to
lower Manhattan he's going to have a
central station that operates a big
generator and he's going to kill off gas
in America so he's made a very large
claim for himself when did he start
becoming death he was actually a death
his definites began even as a teenager
and I have a little story in the book
which he told different stories over
time but Paul Israel who so one of the
sort of top scholars of Edison finds
this the most plausible which is that he
worked as a young man on the railroad
starting at about age 12 and selling
newspapers and he was trying to get onto
a train and not making it when one of
the conductors reached down to get him
and pulled on his ears and he said from
that moment on is you're never was quite
the same and he wasn't completely deaf I
mean that his deafness got worse but one
of the endearing aspects of Edison is
he's such an optimist about everything
and so to him even as deafness was an
advantage because it kind of sealed off
a lot of the distractions of life
there's a picture of him in the book
taking a nap why did that make it to the
book well that was very typical of essen
he was a real workaholic you loved what
he did and he would get completely
caught up in his work and then all of a
sudden he'd be exhausted and he would
take a nap but under a table you know on
top of a chair it just and so when I saw
that picture which actually is in the
Smithsonian at an exhibit I thought I
really want to have that where was he
from originally married children well he
grew up in Michigan really his mother
ran a rooming house his father was not
very successful man who tried various
trades and Edison was very much
self-taught he taught himself to be a
telegrapher and he became the best
telegrapher and it was really that that
got him into inventing he was trying to
figure out how to make Telegraph's work
better it was also how we knew quite a
bit about electricity about the time
that he moved to menlo park he married
and had several small children and then
later his wife who I think one could
safely say was very neglected because
really what he was in love with was his
work she died and he then married a very
young and lovely woman had some more
children with her I think in the end e
at about five kids and that was his
married life was he political at all he
was a Republican but no he was not very
political really his life was his
inventions and developing them as an
inventor he was completely interested in
the commercial application of whatever
he invented and if he if it couldn't be
made commercial he wasn't interested
before we go on can you describe the
difference between direct current
electricity and alternating current AC
vs. DC DC the electrons just move in one
straight line along the copper wire that
is conducting them and it can't go very
far so one of Edison's problems though
he didn't see it as a problem was that
his direct current generators only could
send electricity maybe about half a mile
as they improved maybe three-quarters of
a mile so his vision when he thought of
electrifying the world was that there
would be an Edison generator about every
mile so you can see who is planning to
be very rich alternating current however
goes along the wire like this it's got a
frequency and it's moving and so it sets
up a little electron
magnetic field around it and when you
take alternating current wires and you
wind them around one another in a
certain kind of a way you can increase
the voltage enough that you can send it
very long distances and that was
Westinghouse's a real contribution to
this early field was that he created a
commercial transformer because that's
what they're called you transform the
electricity up you send it where you
want to send it and there's a
transformer at the other side and with
many fewer coils of electricity and that
brings the electrical electricity down
to a you know a level that's safe for
people to then use it in their
appliances and have it coming in like
their houses do you have an electric
electricity background of any kind no I
have to say I did not know a thing about
electricity when I started this book my
husband is a scientist and he was very
amused at the idea that I was writing a
book about electricity where's your
headquarters I live in Baltimore doing
what their full-time I just I'm a
historian and I write books and what
book is this for you this is book 3 uh
there are drawings in here I mean
there's schematics and stuff like that
where did you go to get this kind of
information how did you learn it well
the schematics are present in many books
that are trying to explain about
electricity because since it is
invisible it helps to have it laid out
for you and so I found numerous
schematics that I found very helpful
because as I said nothing about
electricity and had my father-in-law
John Ross who's an artist render them
for me so that that would help others
who were learning about the mysterious
fluid as it was called get some sort of
an understanding of electricity how did
you make sure that you were right about
all this I had many people read the book
did you have to go to experts on
electrical engineers on my life matters
um no I had
I mean bet yes some of these people were
experts obviously one of the people I
had read it was my husband what kind of
a scientist is he he's actually a doctor
and a neuroscientist and a geneticist
your second person that you talk about
is this fellow right here is it Nicola
or nicol nicola Nikola Tesla Nikola
Tesla how old would he have been in this
picture probably about 22 what's his
story well Nikola Tesla is truly one of
the great characters and I had heard of
him but I really didn't know that much
about him until I started working on
this and he is a very brilliant Serbian
immigrant whose passion was electricity
and he came to Paris to work in the
Edison factory there and he had had this
great epiphany even before he arrived in
Paris about alternating current what
year would that have been that would
have been in the late 1870s so we're
still around 1879 right so what was
there his epiphany came he came to work
for Edison Electric in eighteen eighty
two so as when the Pearl Street Station
gets up and running in Manhattan Edison
who has visions of a worldwide empire
has already sent his aide Charles
Batchelor to Paris to begin continental
Edison and Nikola Tesla goes there to
work for him and Tesla has many strange
phobias one of which he likes to do
everything in threes and so when he
would start his morning before he went
to work there he would go and swim laps
it was a pool on the the sin and he
always did 27 laps and when he would
walk he would try and make sure that he
didn't walk you know more than something
that was divisible by three he had a
horror of germs he couldn't stand to be
in the same room as women with pearls so
but he was very
charming and very erudite now Edison was
really a self-educated man he read his
way through entire libraries but Tesla
had a university education and so he
came into this from a much more educated
standpoint and as I say he had a passion
for electricity and no one had been able
to figure out how you could run a motor
on alternating current Addison used
direct current and it was fine for
lights and it was fine for motors so
when he went out to sell his product to
people you know let me bring electricity
into your factory let me bring
electricity into your office he could
offer not only lights but machines this
was not true for alternating current and
Tesla was the one who figured out in his
mind how to create a motor that would
operate on alternating current and when
he went to work for Edison in Paris he
tried to convince them that alternating
current was a superior form of
technology to DC but you have to
understand the circumstance Tesla is
this very junior engineer he's a Serbian
he's a you know kind of a eccentric
fellow Edison is world famous he's
created electricity he's invented the
light bulb he's invented everything that
makes the light bulb work I mean he's
come up with the generators in his
Factory he's come up with all the the
wiring system's the switches it's a huge
accomplishment and so who's to pay any
attention to Nikola Tesla you know he
just seems like a dreamer he leaves
Paris after a couple of years and goes
to New York still wanting to convince
Edison that alternating current is the
way to go and he can't convince Edison
Edison for one thing believes it
alternating current is dangerous because
its operating at these higher voltages
and he really wants nothing to do with
it but there's another aspect to it i
believe which is that Edison took
enormous pride in the fact that he
had developed every aspect of this
system and for him the idea of adopting
someone else's technology is superior to
his I think was a bitter pill and he
wanted nothing to do with it and so
Tesla quit and he was cottony on to the
American system of business and decided
he was going to be very practical and so
he started went into business with a few
investors and started an Arclight
company and essentially he was cheated
and meanwhile he's still trying to find
someone to take up this alternating
current engine and a better system of
transmission called polyphase
electricity now what about his personal
life did he ever marry he never married
and as very strange as this will sound
his great love in life with a white
pigeon oh I just happen to have a
picture of that pigeon that you have
from this book right here is this the
pigeon apparently so that comes from the
Tesla Museum in Belgrade as I say Tesla
was a very strange man he had loads of
friends he was actually very prominent
in New York society once he became very
famous but he had a real affinity only
for pigeons and this was the pigeon that
he particularly loved and is evidence
there's a photo of it well near the end
of the book and I'll try to find it it's
almost might be useful to read that part
of him because once you read this it
does change your view of this man this
you get this out of John J O'Neill's
book now who is he he was a science
editor at The Herald Tribune and a great
friend and admirer of Tesla's and he
wrote the first biography of him and to
mom to me I mean it was just such a
mesmerizing book because it's very
saturated with Tesla and the person he
was this you started by writing say one
evening the elderly almost cadaverous
nikola tesla told john j O'Neill about
the white pigeon while
were sitting and visiting in the lobby
of the hotel new yorker-- is at the same
hotel new yorker-- that's on eighth
Avenue right now probably quote i love
that pigeon yes I loved her as a man
loves a woman and she loved me as long
as I had her there was purpose in my
life then one night as I was lying in
bed in the dark solving problems as
usual she flew in through the open
window and stood on my desk as I looked
at her I knew she wanted to tell me she
was dying when the pigeon died something
went out of my life up to that time I
knew that with a certainty that I would
complete my work no matter how ambitious
my program but when that something went
out of my life I knew my life's work was
finished did John O'Neil go on to
describe any more about that what he
said about the pigeon that was really
pretty much what he had to say and I
think John O'Neil was very taken aback
because it was a confession really from
someone he admired an enormous amount
and it's really quite poignant what do
you think he was mrs. near the end of
his life mm-hmm and at the end if I get
it right he was he died when he was 86
years old right in 1943 when he lost his
mind or was this really well I think he
was always very eccentric and I in many
ways lived in in his own world the
reality with Tesla is that he invented
many many things only alternating
current ever really became a commercial
reality and Tesla has a very fervent
following of people who were fascinated
by him because he invented all kinds of
things that as I say never were
commercially developed but were very
prescient for instance he invented a
remote control and this was so far he
was so far ahead of everyone that no one
knew what to make of it um he developed
a huge boat just look like a big toy and
he could make it you know using remote
control this is 8 you know the 1890s
using a remote control he's sending it
around on the water and people just it
wouldn't occur to them oh well we'll use
this remote control to open
closed doors or to turn things on and
off it just was like magic to them he
also was way ahead on radio when his
entire laboratory burned down Tesla was
a man who had many dramatic turns in his
life and Marconi beat him to it how did
his lab burn down well he shared the lab
it was downtown in lower Manhattan he
shared it with a another factory and
this factory had all kinds of grease and
flammable stuff around so it didn't have
anything to do with his lab it had
nothing to do with electricity he just
really had the bad luck to be in a
building that went up in flames because
of another tenant what year would that
have been that was a must have been
about 18 95 or 96 but you set it up here
that he was fighting Edison for AC vs.
DC right so what happens is Edison has
invented the light bulb in 1882 he gets
his Pearl Street Station up and running
and you know it's a great historic
accomplishment September for 1882 and
Edison then has all kinds of other
competitors who are basically infringing
on various patents and so he figures
eventually his legions of lawyers and he
had legions of lawyers would fight off
these other people and they would be
gone from the scene and he would have
the electrical world to himself and then
in 1886 so Edison's been up and running
for four years he's expanding all over
the place all of a sudden along comes
George Westinghouse now these other
people that Edison has as competitors he
doesn't take very seriously because they
are infringing on on his technology
Westinghouse is really a different story
he's a very successful a very bold
Pittsburgh entrepreneur he has two
extremely successful companies plenty of
money and a different kind of technology
which is this alternating current that
you know gets stepped up on transformers
and stepped down and so imagine that
your salesman for edison and you go into
a fast-growing american city or town and
america is growing fast we're having
record levels of immigration and it's
the Great era of urbanization so imagine
you go in and you say ok we would like
to to sell you an electric generator it
will operate all your lights that will
operate all your machines but it can't
go more than a mile the Westinghouse
people come to the same town and say
we'd like to sell you our alternating
current generator and as your town grows
we can expand it all you'll need is this
one generating system we can put it on
the outskirts of town because we can
send the electricity in well who do you
think you're going to go with now the
disadvantage that Westinghouse was had
says he did not have he could not run
motors he had not met nicola tesla nor
had nikola tesla announced to the world
his great invention of a motor that
operated on alternating current so but
already alternating current very quickly
became a significant problem in
competition for edison now the irony of
all this is that Edison actually also
had patents to European developed
alternating current and he could
certainly have incorporated that and in
fact everyone in this company was
begging him to but as I say he was very
stubborn I think he had enormous sense
of pride and he clung to the idea that
alternating current was unsafe and
instead what he decided to do was to use
his enormous prestige and influence to
try and drive a stake through the heart
of anything to do with alternating
current George Westinghouse was you say
from Pittsburgh what kind of education
that he had was he a family man what was
he like personally
well he was in the end he was actually
my favorite of these three very
compelling idealistic man very reserved
in public but very charismatic and
dynamic in private and he had grown up
in schenectady his father operated an
agricultural implements shop his father
also invented things and put them
together so Westinghouse had a very
practical you know sort of on the ground
education he briefly went to college
which he did not like he fought in the
Civil War and he made his fortune
inventing air brakes it's hard for us to
believe but when America operated on
railroads and trains until the air brake
came along which was oh I guess in the
1870s you couldn't stop a train very
easily with you had men who would jump
off down from the roof of the Train the
car and turn these things to try and
slow it down so the one-legged train men
or break man was a fixture of Gilded Age
america until westinghouse came up with
these air brakes so the engineer of the
train could stop the train and so you
can imagine he made a great fortune on
this in part because he was a very very
good businessman he then also using
electricity developed a whole systems of
signaling for trains so he was really
someone who had made a fortune in the
toughest corporates atmosphere which
there's a world of railroads and now a
sudden he appears and when Edison heard
this he was very angry he said tell
Westinghouse to stick to air brakes I
mean he did thought that electricity was
his arena and stay out and he also felt
he said sures anything Westinghouse is
going to kill people with this with his
AC and Edison was very concerned that
that electricity be seen as benign be
seen as safe so that it could spread
widely without people worrying that it
would kill you mayor
children uh wessing house was totally
devoted to his wife unlike Edison who
had wives but you know it's very
neglectful of them he had a very sweet
relationship in marriage with her he
especially set up wherever he was that
there would be a telegraph or telephone
so that he could speak to his wife every
day no matter where he was and he had
one son with her difference in age of
these three they're actually Edison and
Westinghouse are about the same they're
in their 30s as this whole war of the
electric currents gets going and
develops and Tesla is a bit younger than
they are but not by much so he might be
about 30 and they would both be about 35
I wrote down the three men and when they
died George Westinghouse died March 12
1914 he was 68 right and Edison died
1931 he was 84 and Tesla died 1943 he
was 86 line money who had the most money
along the way in this process who made
the most I guess both from electricity
the person who made the most money
finally was Westinghouse and that is
because his technology triumph Edison
certainly made money on electricity and
he had he was backed by JP Morgan and
various Wall Street money men but as the
technology took far longer to develop
than they ever expected so you remember
I had mentioned that in 1879 Edison
announces I'm going to you know light up
Manhattan and gives the impression it
will be a matter of weeks or months well
actually it was almost three years and
it was far longer than anyone expected
and there were many many pitfalls and
problems in the end he Edison put up a
lot of his own money in order to develop
as his company but he did have Wall
Street behind him Westinghouse had a lot
of his own money and he had Pittsburgh
money behind him
that never had any kind of a successful
company and what happens is so
Westinghouse has come on the scene he
start he's announced he's starting his
company it's early 1886 by the end of
that year in 1886 they run their they
set up and get running their first
project which is a department store in
Buffalo and what was interesting about
this is this is a hugely historic event
but in typical Westinghouse fashion he
says nothing about this to the
newspapers or anyone else when anything
that happens with us and he is full of
ballyhoo everyone knows it's happened
he's boasted about it he's promoted it
he's terrified as you know any
competitors Westinghouse is very you
know on a quiet and so around
Thanksgiving of 1886 they run their
first alternating current generator and
send power a distance into this the
fanciest department store in Buffalo
Adam and Meldrum and everyone comes to
see this and it's you know quite an
accomplishment and that's the beginning
but still Westinghouse doesn't have a
motor and in 1886 so almost a year I
mean 1888 to almost a year later is when
Tesla finally he's managed to you know
get himself some backers he has written
his patents he's developed his machines
and he has begun to meet important
people and he is persuaded to go to
Columbia College and before the his the
world of professional engineers deliver
a lecture and demonstrate all of his
machines and this is a sensation I mean
everyone understands immediately that
here is a new electrical tighten and
that this is in fact he could be on the
level of an Edison in Westinghouse who's
heard about this even before it happens
immediately swoops in and buys those
patents because Westinghouse
is very willing to he himself as an
inventor westinghouse and he always
remembers how much trouble he had one
who's trying to convince people to
underwrite the air brake to financing so
he's very generous to inventors of any
kind he swoops in he buys Tesla's patent
he brings him to Pittsburgh and the
whole electrical fraternity is kind of a
buzz because now Westinghouse is going
to have what he has lacked in his fight
with Edison and that is the motor is
that is this all public at the time as
it talked about in the newspapers oh yes
very much so is it interest to the
public at large hugely interest of
interest because this is this era the
Gilded Age at the end of the 19th
century when people are enormously
interested in technology of every kind
technology has changed the world so
dramatically already there's a sense
that everyone is in the middle of a
continuing revolution when you look at
railroads first of all they've
eliminated space in a way or distance in
a way nothing else has the Telegraph has
done it even more so when you think I
given my book the example of JP Morgan
because it used to be to hear from their
office in London would take weeks now it
takes seconds so there's this tremendous
sense of the world shifting under your
feet and becoming smaller and closer and
when people look at the fortunes that
were made from things like railroads in
the telegraph they're very interested in
a technology that's going to light up
the world not with a flame but you know
with something the mellow light of an
Italian sunset was one description and
also it's going to run machines I mean
one of the things that was so
interesting about working on this book
was trying to recreate the world without
electricity this world where you got
everywhere either you know on a horse or
on a railroad or on a boat
on your feet and then also we're just
the rhythms of daylight were so much
more part of people's lives and that
there weren't machines anything I mean
there were steam engines but most
ordinary people did not have machines in
their lives so almost anything you did
was just pure human power or horsepower
one of the things that comes out of your
book is the way that Thomas Edison
treated dogs well this takes us to the
beginning of the war of the electric
currents and the wharf electric currents
is a battle that went on really you know
over a period of almost well I guess you
could say probably about just under ten
years and it begins with Edison deciding
that he's going to change his mind about
how he feels about capital punishment he
had always stated publicly that he was
against it and promote not only capital
punishment but capital punishment of a
very specific sort electrocution and not
only electrocution but electrocution
using alternating current generators
from the Westinghouse company and I I
date the beginning of the war of
electric currents to december eight 1887
so Westinghouse his company's been up
and running for almost two years his
first successful client this department
store in Buffalo was your previous and
we we don't really know what set Edison
off on this decision to really launch
what I consider the most vicious and
macabre feud in American corporate
history but something had happened and
he changed his mind and he now not only
endorsed this idea but helped actively
to promote it and one of the ways that
he did this is a very strange fellow
named Harold Brown sort of steps out of
nowhere and begins attacking
Westinghouse
as far as any anyone's been able to
figure out this he was self-appointed
sort of anti AC warrior but he was
wonderful convenience for Edison who was
happy to do whatever he could to help
him and eventually actually put him on
his payroll secretly and so Harold Brown
needed to show scientifically that
alternating current should be taken up
by the New York State death Commission
as opposed to anything else any other
kind of electricity so he began going
out to Edison's Edison now had a new
bigger and more wonderful laboratory out
in West Orange he left Menlo Park and he
was into a sort of industrial scale of
invention and west orange is today open
to the public well actually yes and it's
been preserved by the National Park
Service so he goes out there and they
buy dogs from local children and they
start electrocuting dogs and what
they're basically trying to figure out
is how much more quickly you can
electrocute a dog with AC vs DC and once
they've done this then he goes back into
manhattan no one knows this is going on
he goes back into manhattan and invites
the electrical engineers and overall
fraternity to a demonstration he doesn't
say what it is he's going to do and they
all turn out to see this and he begins
electrocuting these dogs and it's just
appalling and it isn't a convincing
demonstration because he begins by
trying to electrocute them with direct
current and the dogs don't die right
away but obviously they're being
tormented and their great distress um
and did he tell them why he I mean he's
the direct current man why does he well
he wants he wants to show that they
don't die from direct current and then
he's going to apply alternating current
but by the time he gets to the point
that he's going to apply alternating
current the crowd is in such an uproar
because this is so cruel such a cruel
thing to
see that he is never he kills the dog
off with alternating current but it's
the same dog he's given direct current
to he's not able to complete the full
range of demonstration that he wanted to
make he does do that subsequently and
then when the state death commission is
not one hundred percent convinced Edison
steps forward and offers his Menlo Park
laboratory and at that demonstration
they kill not just dogs but also a calf
and a horse and this is enough to
convince the state that yes what they
need is some Westinghouse generators to
operate their electric chairs and Harold
Brown then further gets himself
appointed official New York State
executioner why does Thomas Edison want
the New York State people to use the all
turn the AC of Westinghouse because he
wants it to be known as the
executioner's current and he wants when
someone dies in the electric chair he
wants the world to think of this as
being Westinghouse tell the world that
he doesn't but among the at headquarters
all the Edison executives are kind of
chortling among themselves and writing
back and forth about you know how
wonderful this is this Westinghouse know
what he's up to absolutely and he is
doing he hires a very famous or a
silver-tongued lawyer named bork bork
Cochran who's also a politician because
what happens is they've now got their
method of execution but first of all
then they have to have their victim and
a man known as William Kemmler who's
referred to as the hatchet fiend murders
his girlfriend in Buffalo and he it's
not the name he uses he starts he's
known in Buffalo is John court but he's
quickly emerges that his real name is
William Kemmler
that he's fled from Philadelphia with
his paramour and who he has murdered
with an axe and he emerges as the first
person who's going to die in the
electric chair and Westinghouse then
proceeds to as far as we can tell
there's no absolute proof but I mean
kemler couldn't afford someone like
Bourke Cockran and there then ensues
this long drama of Cochran constantly
challenging and appealing the use of
electricity saying that this would be
cruel and unusual punishment because no
one could really guarantee that Kammler
in fact would be killed on the first
effort and he would then have to be
executed twice what's the date of this
this all begins about oh the early eight
I'd say early 1888 and then it's lost I
mean that the case drags on and Kammler
dies on august six 1890 and what his
lawyers tried to show is it brings
people who've been struck by electricity
some of there alive I mean obviously
many people not electricity by lightning
I mean obviously many people who were
struck by lightning died but there are
people who are struck by lightning and
they live so his point was that no one
really knew what it would take to
actually kill someone electrocute
someone but he was not able to convince
the courts and so William kendler was
sentenced to die and became the first
man to die in the electric chair on
august six 1890 and in fact it was a
terrible botch they didn't give enough
electricity to kill him and they thought
he was dead and the 28 or so people
assembled to see him die went up and
they realized that he was still alive
people were fainting it was so hideous
some people had to go out into the
corridor just you know to be ill and
they gave him a second much more
prolonged jolt of electricity whereupon
he was finished off you actually have
this paragraph but the blood was
continuing to is from Kim
a small finger wound his heart still had
to be beating the physicians around the
limp figure we called as one yelled and
horror great god he's alive another
ordered turn on the current see he
breathes gasp a third what was the
impact of all this well it didn't seem
to stop continued use of the electric
chair but it did I think cast some doubt
on you know whether AC was a stone
killer and meanwhile the reality
remained that Westinghouse was selling
his-his system of electricity with great
leaps and bounds and in fact the so this
is the first battle and you can say okay
Edison one he managed to get someone
electrocuted with alternating current
and he in Harold Brown Edison and Harold
Brown then began to work the legislature
state legislatures in order to get
alternating current band but what they
hadn't figured on is that arc lights
which had really taken often were all
over the country arc lights would be
banned if you banned alternating current
and the the local people who operated
the arc lights would come out and
testify it was very hard for an outside
or even one so prestigious as Edison to
persuade a legislature when the locals
were saying wait you're going to shut
down this entire industry so that that
was the first battle and I think you
could safely say that yes Edison one
that but he also lost it because at this
point his refusal to take up alternating
current was really creating troubles for
his company and his competitors had
taken up alternating current of course
Westinghouse was busy suing all of them
because he felt that this was his
technology and in the end Edison lost
his company his electric company J
p morgan who held the great majority of
the stock and sort of managed it for
people in 1892 looked at how the edison
company was doing looked at how the
thomas houston company was doing which
was run by a business and inane charles
coffin he'd been a very successful shoe
salesman and he turned out he was a very
good an electrical company chieftain and
what he saw was it Thomas Houston which
had taken up alternating current as a
system that it offered to his its
customers was making profits of 25% the
Edison Company which did not use that
technology was making profits of twelve
percent and he decided he was going to
merge these two companies and create an
entity called General Electric and that
Edison was going to be out and this was
a very very bitter blow to Edison he had
tremendous pride in having it was really
his greatest work and so yeah because
we're almost out of time you go up to
where we are today you still have the
Westinghouse corporation even though it
wasn't broadcasting it's no longer
alright General Electric and what about
Tesla is there anything left from him
there's really nothing left of Tesla and
since we're almost out of time let me
just say quickly that the war of the
electric currents continued in two other
big battlefields one was Chicago of 1893
the white city which was an incredible
showcase for electricity and that that
was another big battle now it's between
GE and Westinghouse and Westinghouse
really wanted this and he came out of
near bankruptcy to arrive in chicago and
essentially just swooped in and stole
that contract from GE by simply offering
a far better deal and then the next
battleground was niagara falls again at
jpmorgan enterprise and who would
transmit alternating current and in this
case having the Tesla patents was
absolutely the trump card
remember GE is JP Morgan's entity you
can imagine he desperately would have
liked them to do the niagara power
business but he in the end their
electrical advisors said to them you
know this is a contract which has to go
to Westinghouse because the Tesla
patents are unique and invaluable and
actually in the end Westinghouse had to
come to a patent sharing agreement with
GE because he was so repeatedly attacked
by them you know on Wall Street that he
felt like he would lose his company in
the end these three men how were they
financially well in the end Edison was
always rich in part because he got into
the movie business because of his
phonograph and he made lots and lots of
royalties from that Westinghouse had
plenty of money he had 50,000 employees
many businesses mean it was a real
corporate Titan in a way that Edison
wasn't because he was backed by Wall
Street in ways that Edison couldn't be
because after that whole episode with JP
Morgan losing his company Edison wanted
nothing more to do with Wall Street
Tesla really sank into penury I mean was
heartbreaking he actually had given up
his patents his royalties in order to
save Westinghouse's electric company at
some point because he thought he was on
at the cusp of a big career in which he
would have many patents many products
and many riches and it just didn't work
out that way other things that he tried
to do he never could commercially
develop and so he was actually supported
in part by the Serbian government and in
part or i guess the Yugoslavs of mint
and in part by the westinghouse company
but actually not in a very munificent
way how long did this take you to do two
years what was the toughest part of it
um I would say learning to understand
how electricity worked the cover of this
book has a photograph of the FW
Woolworth Building exactly where is that
if you stand at City Hall and lower man
Hatton and you look to your right and up
you would see exactly this and as it
still looked like this today oh yeah
just as magnificent they light it like
this today you know that I don't know I
guess I haven't been in low I go to
Manhattan lot but I guess I've been down
at City Hall to see it but I wouldn't
surprise me what's next for jill jones
well it's another Gilded Age book but I
don't want to say too much more than
that also business and technology the
fellow that endorses your book Erik
Larsen who was here to talk about his
book on the white city said about the
same thing that you do you think you're
ever going to clash a he endorses your
book you're gonna clash on the same
subjects no because I know what I'm
writing about and I have some idea what
Eric's writing about and I think they're
you know very different things so I
think we'll be fine again the cover of
the book of empires of light our guest
has been jill jones thank you very much
for joining us thank you so much for
having me